you guys how are you I'm gonna start
with love the movie congrat nails thank
you congratulations on the film I'm
switching it back to the two of you you
guys both have over two million
followers on Instagram and I'm very
curious how much time do you think about
what you're gonna post before you post
it like is there like a double thought
but when you have that many followers
like yeah cuz there's some yeah my fans
like they don't like these skating
videos I post they want me to post
videos of like or things of me at like
these photo shoots are like oh my god
he's so great photo shoots but I you
know sometimes I want to share things
like if it was just my friends and stuff
that I would share probably more like
personal stuff like stuff about my
skating life and always like either make
my hobbies like fluting fluting playing
the flute and Jared fluting yeah I mean
there's some things I don't know like
I'll take I'll have like a couple
pictures and like my like the inventory
and like I'll think about posting them
but I'm like I think I like that and
then you just move to the next one but I
mean they really just love like the
behind-the-scenes stuff and like that
kind of stuff cool I'm the the superhero
genre is the most popular on the planet
right now all the comic book movies
people just love them what do you think
it is about the genre that so many
people are responding to yeah yeah I am
I think it's the high energy that it
incorporates but this movie for sure
also the fandoms are always really huge
we were in surrounding these of these
kind of movies but this movie for sure
incorporates a lot of different elements
oh you have not seen before in in
superhero movies which has a lot of
levity it has a lot of hard sense of
humor and one thing I think that Zac
said that was really on the nose is that
this movie has a superhero protagonist
that is not dreading having to save the
world again
he's so stoked about having to be able
to have these powers and it's not a
burden for him it's like a gift you know
blue yeah
yeah I mean it's I mean what kid or what
person doesn't want to be a superhero
it's light hearted and it tackles like
everything that needs to be talked about
even family it's almost like you two got
along on set Lord oh no not at all Betty
okay uh when you think back I would
imagine making this movie was a complete
blast but when you think back on the
shoot what's like the day or two that
you will always remember Oh Jack
Sprague's just pranks I some pretty good
Frank's uh but no I think we had a lot
of fun at the school doing the scenes of
the school that stuff I know this seems
over all together you having at the
carnival and your montage my training
montage that was fun that was a multiple
multitude of days though those are many
days they turn on nervously were to like
hit him with the bat that you were that
yeah that was scary who's this when I
when I had to hit him with the bat there
was a wire up my arm do they get explode
and I was like if this malfunctioned my
arm will and like don't break I think
it'll explode so yeah I killed it hit
him hard right I already got to go
but listen congratulations in the movie
you both need such a great job cool
you